Democrat senators are in a panic and
trying to talk Joe manchin out of
launching a third party presidential
campaign and spoil Biden's re-election
chances the moderate Democrat remains
Coy on what his plans are there's been a
lot of talk recently about the
possibility of you running for president
what do you make of that is that just
you know the drama no the bottom line is
is that where everyone's trying to find
this sensible reasonable middle in both
the Democrat and Republican party have
gone to extremes
Colorado Democrat John Hickenlooper says
he spoke to manchin telling Politico
quote I've advised him against it I
think it would be a terrible idea it
would help Donald Trump he looked at me
and he nodded
all right Sandra
no terrible idea and anybody who says
that there are any Democrats who say
they're worried about this idea must be
in the smaller uh the smaller group of
Democrats who have said that they
actually want him to run for re-election
because we know that there's a majority
of Democrats have gone on the record now
saying that they don't want Joe Biden uh
to run for reelection that being said
where's the money Jessica I I may defer
my time to you considering these
multiple interviews in which people are
expressing nervousness that early
fundraising for Joe Biden has not
delivered as they hoped if things are so
great in the country as this White House
continues to tout especially on the
economy and otherwise why wouldn't the
money just be flowing through the door
and I think a lot of Democrats might be
asking that question right now I think
go ahead and answer it right
um well he just started his campaign
formerly last Saturday he has a bunch of
fundraisers scheduled I I really don't
think that money is going to be a
problem on either side frankly and
people top fundraisers billionaires they
always come true and it costs a billion
dollars to win an election now and both
of them whoever the Republican candidate
is and Joe Biden will have that money in
terms of what's going on with this third
party issue this surrounds an
organization called No Labels that
they did a good thing they created the
problem solvers caucus in Congress which
is a very good thing it's moderate place
to go Republicans and Democrats
um but they've really gone too far now
so it used to be that we need a good
alternative to what's out there they say
Trump's an existential threat now
they've decided that Joe Biden is quote
too radical
um and hasn't gotten anything done so
Democrats are flipping out about that
and for good reason they release their
map of how a No Labels candidate so a
third party candidate could win the
White House and two-thirds of the
electoral votes that that candidate
would be getting came from states that
Joe Biden won so even if Biden was going
to be able to recreate his map he would
be losing then as a result of there
being a third candidate whether it's a
Joe manchin or a moderate Republican
they would toy with anything there um
and it's really dangerous and there have
been a bunch of pieces lately going
after Nancy Jacobson it's high up there
and her husband Mark Penn who was one of
Bill Clinton's pollsters and
um they're not very popular these days
around DC Jesse the if it is Mansion if
he decides to be a third party candidate
it not only affects Biden obviously but
it also you lose that senate seat so
does that make any sense at all so he's
going to lose the Senate to Justice he's
down 40 points his seat's up what in
2024 so he's trying to save face bailout
on the Senate re-election campaign and
go nationally with a third party run and
he'll play spoiler he won 300 000 votes
in West Virginia
Biden only won Georgia by 11 000 he only
won Arizona by ten thousand you don't
think Mansion could get a couple
thousand in some of these razor thin
margin states to play spoiler absolutely
but if I were Joe Biden I'd be worried
about the Ros whistleblower that just
came out today and said the Department
of Justice blocked two felony charges
against his son blocked investigations
into the big guy gave Hunter Biden a
heads up when there were search warrants
at two properties and then they have
this text message where Hunters
threatening the Chinese saying my dad's
right here and if you don't pay up now
there's going to be consequences I don't
know how long the Democrats could ignore
this stuff but I mean how many
whistleblowers is it going to take
I'd love to get into the whistleblowers
but what about RFK how does he play into
any of this I you're a fan of our I
think if RFK ran independently he would
peel off a lot of Republicans I think if
manchin ran independently he would peel
off a lot of Democrats that's why I want
to see four four I want to see four you
know I I but it's really hard for me to
continue because you know I always go by
the advice of John Hickenlooper yeah
it's the first time we ever
caught Hickenlooper for advice look
Mansions always had two pluses number
one like Rand Paul he's always the odd
man out so his vote always counts more
than all of his peers and that makes his
status elevated uh and also it's a
Democrat he's kind of acts like an adult
right he you wouldn't see him or RFK Jr
participating in an attack on Riley
Gaines they would not do that or they
wouldn't push a dossey for four years
they wouldn't call riots mostly peaceful
uh they wouldn't they wouldn't uh label
parents as terrorists that the point
being is that moderate Democrats aren't
interested in framing people as bad
they're beyond Politics as punishment
I've seen RFK Jr talk about getting out
of the prison of two ideas so the bottom
line is these are old school Democrats
and I kind of really miss them you know
I kind of like having them around
because they're always your backup guy
right you know when you don't have a
date for the prom Jesse or you need a
Supreme Court Justice yes yes exactly
but it's like you know what so what
fills that whole Democratic party it's
been pretty bad so I think that's why
these these people are attractive even
with even with some of rfk's trembling a
treble troubling uh uh uh Health beliefs
he still comes off as a sane adult
compared to like the dick durbins of the
world which is atrocious disgusting
human being yes we're going to end on
that because I want to put an
exclamation to that